one can go down the list of American
writers who I admire and find great many
of them who come from the Midwest and
who were marked by leaving it I feel as
if you if you look at Mark Twain or
Willa Cather or Fitzgerald or George
Saunders or Kurt Vonnegut there is
something distinctive about their having
come from the Midwest had their
innocence prolonged by an extra year or
two by coming from there and then lost
it at an advanced age in the Eastern
Europe I think they're writing is marked
by that wound but it's difficult to to
do more than gather those examples
together and and point to them when
wants to say moral seriousness but
that's of course you know it's not like
Faulkner and O'Connor are not morally
serious people or Kafka who never set
foot in the Midwest except imaginatively
the nature theatre of Oklahoma so
whenever you actually try to pin down
what it might mean to be Midwestern as a
writer you it's you know you're trying
to pin down a water droplet or something
it's terrible